the last weird rule in chess is called
on pissant which is French for in
passing this rule was introduced at the
same time that pawns were allowed to
move forward two squares on their first
move when that happened sometimes pawns
would move past other pawns without
giving the other pawn an opportunity to
capture which didn't seem fair
so one pissant was invented pay
attention it's tricky
if your opponent's pawn moves forward
two squares which it can only do if it
is that pawns first move and it lands
directly next to one of your pawns then
on your next turn in that turn only you
have the opportunity to capture that
pawn as if it had only moved one square
like this let's take a look at that
again if a pawn is move forward two
squares and lands next to another pawn
that pond can capture the first pawn on
its very next move you move behind the
pawn as if it had moved only one Square
and capture it placing it off the board
you might get some weird looks if you do
this move in a game with someone who
doesn't know but it's an important rule
of chess now that you've learned on
passant let's have you try it